welcome to this video bow any squatches
the opponent's name and this is a new
opponent right yep going to play the
Queens gambit accepted here trying
something new recently and look at this
I mean not really but I found out that
there are some interesting ideas
associated with a setup like this must
be just try to be quick with my moves
and don't question that much if this is
the right move water black is trying for
activity in this kind of setup I wonder
this is right actually how I played this
like Teague's and Quincy to know so I
can actually go can i play you five or
not you five a g4s an issue
interesting
hmm how to play this
can also play for a c5 break this looks
really weird but maybe it is just
totally wrong I don't know efore i was
thinking i can take on f3 and then play
you five no is playing something
conservative okay I can't playing c5
then that was my other end IAM connected
with this okay okay so i just returned
I'd have c5 end which isn't that bad
that's it's a can of a in equal dish
position this should be two nite sis 651
looks tired e equal okay
yeah really quite equal white maybe it's
a little bit better he's a bit quicker
on the files oh yeah I hope it's really
just a little bit mmm and a bit bit
annoying
yeah and a 7s hanging I'm not sure if it
is a huge deal if he really takes only
three okay let's just drop back okay
that's rather conservative going back
95 95 I saw that saw that far too late
ah stupids kunai Queenie 7 SB for
amazing amazing really bungled that up
don't think there was much going on
really but as I really screwed it out
if it takes be 700 yeah doesn't have
many squares with that piece I mean
really not property seven or something
now you can go Quincy aid
when I Quincy eight look to you one
check the sir look to you one chick d
one chick King edge to and nothing much
after that
check check and I just have any squares
but he's got Bishop e3 and then he can
place it on d6 on c5 unfortunately now
that wasn't my money that was a bad game
let's see can I another only little hope
is my better my king is quite active and
I'd be five
okay Mets it's really can only hope for
some kind of miracle down right over to
be four maybe
a three may be employed just looking at
before not that night before such a huge
threat but that's probably simple and
good I don't want to take that makes it
so simple I mean maybe this is a bit
more a bit more complicated at least
I get a pawn to b5 then it's the lost
behind anyway not to be 6 it gets a bit
tricky now well now i have a draw wow
that was really bad play technically
timewise may be wrong our third position
is dead now completely dead
add the promise if you pre move you
might take it take something draw a
third grade play it was really difficult
to screw up that end game which in with
work but you managed now come on check
check black forfeits on time yeah that's
the way to win chess games you you play
a decent game then you play a an
absolutely atrocious endgame here and
then you win on time by blundering
everything you what a great great game
yeah anyway um the thing that really
annoys me is that I really got into
trouble why cannot move forward okay no
it works yeah okay experiment a little
bit in the opening so much was going on
but I got into some trouble here yeah to
be a bit more precise than I think from
here it's a bit that's all it's a bit
tricky already because of that see file
pressure they played perfectly a
perfectly fine but then then screwed up
the endgame here I'm just I'm just worse
check
janya versa I mean with good technical
play I'm lost here here 96 of course
this is the easiest just trade nights
Bishop endgame is a very easy win but
you didn't do that and okay I mean I'm
just hanging on here and yeah this is
this is good now he has to play p5 of
course yeah that's very simple after
that I'm losing but you didn't do that
he allowed b5 and now he absolutely
naught that I threatened 97 b6 if he
goes a phone now of course he's winning
which is yeah anyway ok I'm going here
here here and draw yeah just dead now
you can I do absolutely nothing this is
a dead raw even though the engine says
plus 1 but that's a typical computer
problem the engine doesn't see that I
have a completely I'm completely perfect
for watches I can just shuffle around
and yeah well he shuffled a while then
then ultimately took only five there
eight seconds I mean yeah it'sit's it's
difficult if you're really really quick
you might be able to to manage down 9292
f3 is of course much quicker at six
seconds is difficult I mean I'm not that
slow but
yeah anyway ah thanks for watching